à deux jours de la demi finale nice
versailles de la coupe de france les
petits poucets yvelinois ont pu se
préparer comme les plus grands du
football français au centre technique
national de clairefontaine quarantaine
d'athlètes fontaine c'est le repère de
l'équipe de france et c'est quand on est
petit on voyait envoyer nos stars ici et
là le fait d'être là le fait dans
château dans les chambres des joueurs
c'est la préparation elle est parfaite
de regarder à la clairefontaine où
d'autres reportages ou même que tu quand
on sait que tous les joueurs de l'équipe
de france jeunes ou adultes se
regroupent ici et que nous on a la
chance de profiter de ces installations
c'est magnifique tambours mégaphone
écharpes et drapeaux aux couleurs de
l'équipe les supporters sont venus en
grand nombre pour le dernier
entraînement en yvelines du fc
versailles ils ont battu une équipe de
ligue 2 qui tint ses noirs également à
cet ouvrage ils ont ils su se battre et
jusque là je pense que contredisent les
preuves continuent leur beau parcours et
on leur souhaite c'est bien pour le club
c'est bien pour la ville aussi qu'on
soit connue pour autre chose que pour le
château quoi donc c'est bien c'est bien
pour les gens du club pour les bénévoles
pour les joueurs pour le stage en jetant
plein de plaisirs plein de bonheur de
pouvoir partager ça avec et c'est pour
ça aussi que qu'on joue au foot pour
partager des émotions comme ça venir
nous encourager comme ça pendant toute
la séance et nous on sent que pour eux
c'est très important et plus ou moins
comme je dis ça nous donne de la force à
me donne envie de nous surpasser déjà
pour nous et pour eux encore plus après
la victoire en quart de finale contre
bergerac le 9 février dernier joueurs et
supporters espèrent bien d'accéder à la
grande finale au stade de france il
s'essaye à quelques pronostics
je dirais un partout et
et puis les penaltys on passe et puis au
final ce serait beau c'est une belle
histoire mais après on est gonflé à bloc
et
là on a tous hâte d'y être on a tous
hâte d'être sur le terrain et aux
données tout donner pour gagner ce match
est obligé d'y croire sinon on n'y croit
pas qu'il va y croire pour nous on part
en part pas favori mais on a notre rôle
à jouer dans ce match et on va tout
faire pour remporter ce match on espère
on mérite
vous arrive
[Musique]
une centaine de supporters fera le
déplacement à nice mardi pour la demi
finale pour les autres ils seront devant
leur télévision ou dans les bars et
cafés du centre-ville de versailles qui
prévoit de diffuser le match